good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy hump day it is
Wednesday the middle of the week
congratulations you made it to the hump
now let's get over the hump by humping
someone you love that's so beautiful
Claudia no matter where you are no
matter what season it is what month it
is like I know that you Claudia ashrae
mcclurgia will always get me through
hump day and remind me to hunt my loved
ones that is if that's the Legacy I
leave here on this here Planet I will be
nothing short of grateful
I think that it's part of your legacy I
don't know if you or I don't know how
many Wednesdays ago was the last time
that you let a hump day go by without
letting us know that it's hump day it
must have been a day where there wasn't
a toast you know like a Jewish holiday
or something yeah
speaking of this is sadly our final
episode of the week until Tuesday of
next week because this evening I'm
headed out to North Carolina for shows
in Charlotte and Durham and then I will
be in Birmingham Alabama this weekend
and I will return to New York on Monday
which means the toast will return on
Tuesday so I apologize for the lack of
episodes but you know mogul's got a Moog
mogul's got a Moog I'm excited for all
the toasters who get to see you live in
person this weekend and I need to make a
plan for myself or how I'm gonna enjoy
this little Hiatus I have like some
things that I'm gonna do that I wouldn't
be able to do if we were doing toast but
I need to do more of those things
however maybe you should practice your
driving I should accept Floridians
there's tropical storm Nicole headed our
way could turn into a hurricane could
not it's supposed to make landfall today
so if you're a Floridian especially on
the coast beware of tropical storm Nikki
who knows what she might bring not the
tropical storm having a normal name for
once right and just being like a female
tropical storm Nicole Mallon literally
like that's such an a name it's such a
name who knows what what she'll bring us
maybe just rains and wind she might turn
into a hurricane learning so much about
hurricane culture now that I live down
here so everyone just be perfect paired
hunker down I guess I don't drive if you
don't have to
don't learn how to drive when there's a
tropical storm coming through well
perhaps once the storm passes you could
use this free time to learn how to drive
and speaking of learning how to drive
we've been teasing for a while
um the Vlog is finally up Jackie's
taking her permit test and we don't know
if she passed we don't know if she
failed but the only way to find out is
go to patreon.com the toast and the blog
is people are loading it as some of our
best work
our vlogging skills were so on point in
the last two weeks we have our Halloween
Vlog up also so if you do join patreon
you'll get access to that and people are
saying that's their most favorite blog
ever it's truly unhinged because you get
more Halloween content you know you go
like we're in costume for half the Vlog
just like being psychotic varis and
Damon it was really premium stuff on the
patreon uh end of October early November
there's really never been a better time
to join in my opinion but whatever does
my opinion mean nothing your opinion
means everything to me mclared you mean
the world to me you are my everything
you are the only thing that matters
matters to me
beautiful per usual and I mean it you
know we've got a great show today it's
Wednesday which means it's dear toasters
day which is really just one of my
favorite things on the planet to do
um and we've got a real real tough
decision to make for our third and final
I read it honestly I have no idea what
to do okay hopefully maybe it's
something that I weirdly have experience
in you know uh I don't think it is
you don't know everything about me
that's true but I do and I know that you
probably don't have a similar story to
the third deer toasters
um and we're coming off of election day
you know it's the Wednesday after
election day I think like pretty much
all the races were called
there's still a few that are like too
close to call I hope everyone got the
results that they were hoping for
um even though that's not how elections
work
um but it did get me thinking I was
calling I spoke to Jackie yesterday
um and I don't know if it was just me
but I feel like for the first time
ever I was like really looking deeply
into like how weird influencer culture
is when it comes to voting and election
voting
um and I don't know what in particular
set me off but it was just like a day of
like watching People's content like
talking to their audience like they're
[ __ ] brain dead that like I I
actually at last night I called Jackie I
was hysterically crying I was laughing
so hard because I guess I didn't really
even put it together until like one day
back to back just seeing everyone's
voting content I really realized like
how almost insulting to
our intelligence it is the way
influencers talk to us about voting like
make a plan bring his neck like
it's like it's a corner I go to every
Sunday like it's like the way that
you're talking to us like we're so
[ __ ] stupid no and it's like making
me cackle how do we survive the other
days of the year right we need them to
hand hold us to the ballot no and then
like I think what really did me in was
like it was raining in L.A and like La
influencers were like bring an umbrella
oh what I should bring the umbrella in
the rain I never thought of that like no
it's really like I don't know why
they're talking to us like we're first
graders like it was so honestly like it
was embarrassing no and I wonder if
there's anyone even though I'm sure
there's not who like really is getting
their resources their voting resources
like from influencers no no that's a
good question I'm not sure but then that
also brings up another point where it's
like I don't think yesterday I don't
think I posted like a go out and vote
like I spoke about it on the podcast and
like I don't know I just didn't feel
like I needed to hit every platform with
the same thing that everyone's supposed
to and like there were a few messages
like really irresponsible of you not to
use your platform and I just want to
know if there's anyone listening anyone
who follows me on Instagram who didn't
vote because I didn't post on my
Instagram I just spoke about it on the
podcast because you didn't remind them
to vote and they couldn't have
remembered any other way they didn't see
any messaging elsewhere in their
Community their friends their family
members nobody else mentioned it and if
Claudia had maybe that would have made
all the difference right and so if
that's the case then that's a you
problem not a me problem yeah no I just
don't know how for centuries like people
got out the vote when like there weren't
influencers on Instagram like posting a
picture with their sticker and and
letting you know to make a plan the
sticker thing doesn't bother me because
people want to like Flex like yeah I
voted like it's because it's a it's a
cute sticker I don't mind when people
well I only mind when people post their
sticker when it becomes a thing like if
you didn't right uh oh shame you're Mark
yeah no the sticker thing doesn't bother
me especially people like we're making
cute sticker content it's the obviously
encouraging people to vote as a positive
thing but it's like the tone in which
they do it like is actually insulting
like so you tie your shoes then you get
in your car make a right and don't
forget to bring a snack
like it's like go potty beforehand yeah
or wear a diaper it's literally how you
would prepare first graders for a field
trip yeah no it's like we are all grown
adults we pay our own bills like we make
our own decisions like we know how to
get in the car
and vote and people and this was the
other thing like
and I I will say like we voted early
when you were here so like it really did
take I swear to God three minutes but
everyone's content like we just left
like it took literally 30 seconds like
like it was so easy like we literally
didn't even have to go to the bathroom
like I get it like I get the messaging
but I feel like we've gone we've a lot
of people like have gotten so internet
recently that they don't even realize
how stupid they sound telling people to
take an umbrella out in the rain in L.A
like we know we know umbrellas are
helpful when it's raining yeah agreed oh
so it was just making me giggle Beyond I
was like called Jackie last night you
guys I was in tears like it was so
stupid it was so stupid and also like
the voting messaging which has been
around for a while but it just like
makes me cringe every time is like
people like sexualizing voting like
voting makes me so horny
you know what's one of my turn-ons
voting you don't vote I'm not gonna suck
your dick no and like at its core like
yeah no everyone should vote like if
you're dating someone and like they
don't vote like they don't care like
that's lame but like the phrasing of
like phony makes me wet like I could die
it literally sounds like one of my books
I could die you there should be a spicy
book that you read about voting because
that's how sexy no that's what's next
but like that's what's next like the way
people have been sexualizing voting it's
so weird
it's so weird and like we've been voting
for centuries like it's it's gonna be
okay if you know you don't cream your
pants over about no it was it was
genuinely too much like I was cracking
up
I just think I honestly I don't even
know I just think like it's it's deep
internet culture that like I was looking
at from just a human POV and I'm like
this is dumb yeah no voting is important
it's so important and that's the bottom
line but right it's really sexy this
hyperbole the sexualization of voting
the dumbing down of voting yeah
I don't think we need it but I just want
to remind all of our listeners um that
if it is raining it's super important to
bring an umbrella and that could help
from Shield you from the rain
that is you know at its core the the
function of an umbrella so
so something to think about I don't know
take it or leave it it's a little
controversial it's but that's what we do
here you know hot takes at the toast
um
I'm glad we spoke about that because it
was cracking me up last night
um
and we have uh we have to get into the
stories but there was one other thing
there's the new the finale of Love is
Blind dropped I haven't seen it yet
anybody [ __ ] spoils it for me I'll
literally come to your house and kill
you oh my God
um but I will be watching it tonight on
the plane so look out to my stories for
some premium recap content
can't wait for that so I think now
without further Ado it is time for the
past five stories that you need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
Origins the pioneering nature and few
skincare brand has elevated gift sets
that will surprise and Delight everyone
on your holiday shopping list Origins
creates transformative skin care with
naturally derived ingredients to
noticeably improve how skin looks and
feels Origins has a long history of
commitment to our planet by reducing
waste and caring for our natural
resources all of origin's holiday gift
set cartons are plastic free recyclable
and sorts from responsibly managed
forests and for every tree harvested now
trees are planted to date the brand is
plant the brand has planted over 2
million trees around the world so you
can feel good about the gifts you are
giving this season from Origins I feel
like everybody has something from
origins in their skincare routine but
these gift sets that they're selling for
the holidays are so premium because like
first of all give said is such an
underrated thing to get for someone in
your life and skincare is like things
that everybody needs whether they're
really into skincare or not it's a great
gift because who doesn't want to take
care of their skin even if they're not
doing it already
I got like four or five and there's like
just certain people in your life who
it's the perfect gift for they're made
really nice they're wrapped really nice
it's just like a really elegant gift to
give to give gift to give to somebody so
you can get the sets today they're
available at origins.com and it's just
great to spot to uh support a brand that
is taking care of the planet that's
obviously taking care of your skin they
have premium ingredients all natural all
that stuff but then also they're giving
back to the planet planting trees making
sure that they're
sets and their packaging is all good for
the environment and it's just a premium
way to take care of your skin and take
care of the people in your life so again
you can get those gift sets today
available at origins.com make sure you
do that soon so they arrive in time for
the holidays and you're not a last
minute gift Giver because nobody likes
that today's episode is also brought to
you by the match dating app do you do
you match the dating app
is pretty hot and bothered about this
topic understandably it's a juicy one
match believes the most important
relationship is with yourself so in a
world where you can choose to do
anything or do anyone Choose Yourself
first because dating someone who knows
what they want and won't settle for less
that is sexy honestly I love this about
match that they're like really really
obviously a great platform to meet
someone but they're also encouraging
people to like look inward first because
in the words of RuPaul if you can't love
yourself how in the hell are you going
to love somebody else amen
um so match is really encouraging you to
look inward
love yourself
be your own best friend take yourself
out to nice dinners you're not having to
sit like with annoying people who don't
stimulate the conversation you could
just like you know be by yourself maybe
read a book look at people
eat good
if they're the ghosting type be your own
boo
if you do you you already know that the
best relationships show up when you show
up for yourself first there's never been
a better time to try match you can
download the match app today so many
people there's I feel like match is just
one of those companies that has a really
really great record so many people have
met lifelong Partners husbands wives on
Match it's a really premium dating app
and I love that they encourage you
to look after yourself before looking
for someone else so you can download the
match app today there has never been a
better time to try match
love that thank you so much yeah welcome
our stories today are unique I would
like to say but I think we'll very
unique New York will inspire some
interesting conversation okay they're
very like Friday stories but I guess
today is our Friday it's the Friday of
the week for sure it's very Friday
Wednesday
our first story Lauren Conrad and Mitch
she became team Kristen after Laguna
Beach re-watch so the big news of the
week really honestly nothing shocks me
anymore this shocked me we reported a
few weeks ago that Kristen Cavallari and
Stephen Coletti have a Laguna Beach
re-watch podcast with deer media called
back to the beach they've been
re-watching episodes of the show and
they've been bringing on people from the
show producers getting a lot of behind
the scenes tea about the show and I
think also for them it's been like very
healing they talk about it in this
episode that I watch because Lauren
Conrad joined the season finale which
blew my mind not only are her and
Kristen famous Rivals but Lauren has
really disconnected herself from Laguna
Beach the hills and everything that was
once her life with MTV so for her to
come back I was shocked that she agreed
to it they talked about how they even
got her on the show and then they talked
about the season and what they
experienced versus what they've now
watched back no
um I completely agree like genuine shock
was my reaction to this I never in my
life thought I'd see Lauren Conrad even
talk about the hills let alone sit down
it's only Laguna Beach whatever you know
what I mean I talk about that time in
her life let alone sit down across the
table from Kristen Cavallari and I think
one like just this this guest is like
such a big get for deer media and I
think like it's it's such a big deal
like they deserve props because this is
this is actually like a a cultural shift
for real like for a generation that grew
up on this show this like
this changes everything
yeah so I found so many of the things
from the episode to be so interesting
but it also made me realize like
her going on a Laguna Beach rewatch
podcast really is so different from her
going on a Hills rewatch podcast and yes
her and Kristen had like high school
beef but it's not the same thing as like
her Heidi and Spencer you know I don't
think there would ever be them sitting
down to talk about the hills like that
[ __ ] runs so much deeper whereas I think
now looking back we can all be like this
was a petty love triangle that actually
wasn't even that triangular they
explained on the show how Lauren and
Steven had their thing like before
producers came to their high school and
then senior year when the producers were
interviewing everyone they learned about
this previous beef between Lauren and
Kristen that had since been squashed
Lauren and Kristen said they remembered
being at a party and they had it out and
they made up and they were fine but then
when they were telling producers about
their lives producers heard about it and
really dug in deep on that Feud and
Steven and Lauren said all of her senior
years she had different boyfriends she
was hooking up with different people but
like the producers didn't want her to
have anything other than Stephen Stephen
pioning for Stephen so he hearing what
actually happened their senior year
versus what we saw in the show was
really interesting and also like their
perspective on the show Lauren said that
she had never watched a whole episode
even when it was airing back in the day
she used to only watch her scenes and
fast forward through everyone else which
is oh so relatable yeah and she said so
it seems like she has a pretty good
relationship with Stephen throughout the
years they talk she said that she had
covid by herself so she was quarantined
in her quarantining by herself for 10
days around the time that the rewatch
podcast came out so she watched a few
episodes of Laguna Beach season one she
listened to the first episode of back to
the beach and she said I thought you
guys did such a good job you were really
reflective but also like really kind to
everyone so she felt like it would be a
good environment for her to come on and
the only thing that was like
a little you know like there was no um
not disappointing but it felt like they
came on and it's like this whole fight
between Lauren and Kristen over the last
15 years was just imagined because they
were like we never had a problem and
it's like really like how come you mean
in real life yeah like they they just
like I think they have it maybe they
just didn't like [ __ ] with each other
like yeah I think and they're the type
of people who like when they are
together they had had a good time they
have good memories together but maybe
just like with the spotlight it was
either always either Lauren or Kristen
like Lauren narrated the first season
and then she graduated and Kristen
narrated the second season Lauren helmed
the hills and I'm sorry when you keep
like bringing up the fact that they were
in high school like it's so crazy to me
like high schoolers are so young how did
they even legally like get high school
like you're like Lauren graduated so
like Chris was a junior in high school
that is psychotic to me yeah it's really
crazy and then Lauren was the lead for
the hills obviously and it wasn't until
Lauren left the show that Kristen came
on so it was like they could never even
be on the same show together now all of
a sudden they're sitting down and it's
like oh we never had a problem it was
just a misunderstanding which I'm sure a
lot of it was and like they were also in
Hollywood they were the biggest stars
like there are so many different things
going on but it just felt like the last
15 years of before imagined well when
just going back to what you said about
her obviously like would never sit down
for the hills
um I think a lot of that also has to do
because I definitely think like their
beef and everything on the show with
between Lauren Heidi and Spencer it was
definitely like dramatized but then like
it's like afterwards it's like Spencer
and Heidi are still talking about Lauren
and they're still like Heidi was on call
her daddy being like talking [ __ ] about
Lauren's like multi-million dollar
Beauty brand being like I mean she
should have been Kylie like they're
still going after Lauren so it's like of
course but now it's like for Lauren and
Kristen to like get into the beef of the
last 15 years it's so reductive and it's
like it makes no sense because like they
really don't have like they've never
really publicly spoken ill of each other
like I can see them just they've always
been like politely so I could see them
like brushing these last 15 years like I
could see it because like it's really
not that deep but with Lauren and
Spencer and Heidi it's like Spencer and
Heidi don't stop yes and also like the
initial beef between Lauren and Kristen
was potentially like over Stephen and
how right he was came between them and
that's like tell like me trying to care
about someone I liked in high school now
like you couldn't catch me caring the
initial beef between Heidi Spencer and
Lauren is actually kind of serious where
like yeah they accused her of having
like a sex tape and it was real stuff
crazier but that's also just like life
like the [ __ ] that goes down in high
school like isn't real right but I also
feel like it makes sense that Lauren and
Kristen would be even friendly they've
had really similar careers they have two
of them have had the most success from
the show they have real businesses they
have these Empires and they're in
similar spaces but not exactly the same
so I feel like they should be friends
no I completely agree I like ship their
friendship so hard Lauren looked amazing
like when I saw I think I saw like an
Instagram reels trailer on the deer
media Instagram account like I never in
my life would have guessed that's who
was sitting down it's like my eyes took
a second to register to my brain yeah it
was a shock and they were just like cute
with each other also I thought that the
flow of conversation was so good I
thought Stephen and Kristen were really
great podcasters like there was no Gap
the questions that they asked were
really good and I felt like whole made
whole after the whole thing it was
really really enjoyable I think like the
big bombshell from the interview was
they were really just trying to explain
how like their beef over Stephen was
like not
a real thing like Lauren was hooking up
with Talon during that entire season
yeah and other people too like she had
other boyfriends the whole thing was
imagined and if MTV was never there like
she would never have been
pining for Steven her senior year I just
like I've never properly sit down sat
down and thought about the fact that
like Laguna Beach was about 17 year olds
like the fact that they were in high
school like I I'm still stuck on that
like I actually I'm only realizing it
right now like I knew they were in high
school but I never sat down and thought
about it I actually watched a few
episodes maybe five years ago and I was
so surprised to see one like they all
seem really drunk in a lot of the scenes
and they are like 17 16 18 and I thought
like that was so weird at the time when
I watched it as a kid I had no idea like
that's what I was seeing and even Lauren
said she was like what's so crazy is in
the episodes I watched I never really
say much like I have a fee I say like a
line here a line there but I'm not like
saying anything and I guess that it's
just interesting but I also can't
imagine watching footage of myself in
high school like
how cringe that is oh my God like kill
me literally like slit my throat but
that okay you have to watch footage of
yourself in high school and you get to
have like a little TV yeah yeah Dollar
business and I think that's what Lauren
said like because Kristen was like what
was the best part of the show and what
was the worst part and she was like well
the best part is that I got to launch my
brand and I you know have this business
that I don't know that I would have
without these platforms so it's worth it
and what she said was the worst the
worst oh that she didn't have a college
experience really because she like went
to San Francisco she was there four days
a week and then she had to fly home to
do the the voiceovers everything right
so oh that's it but she was like that's
a small price to pay for what we got out
of it no it's so true honestly like I
never thought everything that Lauren
does it's like I keep trying I keep like
calling her Elsie
um you can call her Elsie everything
that LC does
um post Hills is like so refined like
her brand she's very premium so I didn't
know if there was ever like a day was
gonna come that she would actually sit
down and talk about
the experience but now that she did it's
like of course it's in like this very
like I think this was the perfect
conversation it's like I feel like
sometimes when people go on like
podcasts and just talk about like their
you know Peak it's like so tacky
and this was just premium and everyone
looks great and it was like high
production value and it's like number
one on the iTunes Store like it's all
very uh premium elevated yeah and I
think the reason why it's not like tacky
or sad is because that actually wasn't
their Peak I I their Peak has been like
the last 15 years and it just keeps
going and and they're like living the
lives that that they really want I also
thought it was interesting that Lauren
actually lives in Laguna Beach now with
her family wow really yeah
that's so cute yeah it's really it was
really cute I'm trying to think of some
of the other highlights or interesting
points oh a few things that made
headlines was Lauren like apologized to
Kristen for calling her a [ __ ] in Cabo
and Kristen was like I called you a [ __ ]
too and I said really terrible things
throughout you and I'm really sorry and
like they couldn't I don't think they
care anymore no I mean let's be honest
like we all called someone a [ __ ] in
high school like yeah but you don't have
to like watch it again no no there's no
proof yeah also Lauren was like that she
was like that for a season when they
were filming us and we didn't know if it
was going to be a show or anything like
I thought I just like got away with you
know I just made two grand and this
isn't going anywhere and like we just
pulled one over on them they're gonna
film us we're just being ourselves No
One's Gonna pick it up and we made two
grand yeah so she said for that reason
Like That season is exactly who they
were like and so unfiltered and just so
authentic because they did not even know
that they had a show yet
okay how many seasons overall were there
of Laguna Beach so there's Lauren senior
year Kristen senior year and then I
don't know how many seasons they did
after that and then also they went and
did there's three seasons of Laguna
Beach Newport Beach was after that but
like who was on Newport Beach nobody oh
my God I just remember that one scene
from Newport Beach that show never went
anywhere but there was like the white
girl and she was kissing that guy for
the first time and they played Bubbly by
Colbie Caillat
I was like oh my God that's all I
remember that's so funny yeah Newport
like Newport Beach never really took off
um it's just funny when you think about
these shows this happens to me a lot
like shows that Define your childhood
like you associate it with the entirety
of your childhood and then you learn
like as you grow up like Lizzie McGuire
was two seasons right it's crazy but I
think Laguna Beach transitioned into the
hills pretty quickly so we never really
had a lull no and then the city like it
was a lot the city
Good Times yeah
honestly this whole thing is like kind
of making me want to re-watch Laguna
Beach maybe you should and then you
should listen to all the episodes and
get the behind the scenes No I love this
I think this was like a huge moment in
pop culture like this is something like
it'll be in the textbooks
yeah and then we I feel like we've
really come full circle yeah no it's
just something I never I never thought
I'd see the day I never thought I'd see
the day yeah so that was fun
highlight of the week trip down memory
lane
are you ready for our next story which
is also some amazing news yeah Michael
Orr married his longtime girlfriend
Tiffany Roy former NFL player which
inspired the movie The Blind Side has
scored a different kind of touchdown or
who's harder and path to football Glory
was depicted in Michael Lewis's
best-selling book and film The Blind
Side wed his longtime girlfriend Tiffany
Roy in a lavish ceremony on Saturday the
pair of nuptials took place in Nashville
and was attended by about 200 people on
Instagram she said I'm filled with joy
can't believe people took their time and
came to celebrate Michael Oher said my
beautiful wife I love you so much thank
you for blessing me with our family
easily the best single weekend I've ever
been a part of oh my God like not me
being emotional but like Michael Oher's
like starting his own family like I'm
I'm actually gonna cry they actually
have two sons already together and and
two daughters oh my God I love that like
re like you know
like like having your own family after
like you know growing up without one is
like so oh my God I'm like emotional
they've been together for 17 years they
met when he was at University of
Mississippi oh my God everything I
learned about the story makes me love
Michael Lauren more and more now I want
to know like was was the family there
were the two he's there they are they're
not mentioned in this article I don't
know the last last time I watched The
Blind Side I went and found all the
chewies on Instagram one of them is a
toaster and a redhead you're kidding
um
yeah I think it's the um Collins
I think it's Collins was a redhead and a
toaster but like being a redhead is even
more impressive
of course no it's sonish it's sonish
um and I didn't see that they found my
that they followed Michael on Instagram
or vice versa so I think that there was
like trouble I tried to Google it there
wasn't a lot of information because
obviously like people aren't doing the
reporting that we actually matters yeah
and so I just left it at that
oh my God I'm David sorry I didn't mean
to I didn't mean to ruin your day no Day
equals ruined completely yeah but let's
bring it back to Michael Oher has bit
has found love for the last 17 years and
now he is making it official
I I'm so happy for him celebrating his
wedding I mean they were already
together for 17 years and have four kids
so like this isn't what I thought it was
but so it's a love story already I guess
my tears at the beginning were like a
little premature or dramatic but
um still I think this is even more
beautiful than the like than say they
were dating for two years engaged for
one and they got married and like it
could go either way after this like
that's true is a bona fide love story
so you can feel good about it you don't
have too good about it I did check on
them you don't have to worry about them
I feel good about it
so I'd love any excuse to talk about
Michael Oher
I'm so glad he's Found Love I completely
agree and success he just retired in
2016.
oh good I hope he has like a nice
Fortune mm-hmm love that I'm I need to
watch a blind side but like I
emotionally cannot handle it there are
certain movies that like I know are
incredible that like are genuinely too
heavy for me and The Blind Side is one
of them yeah that's some there's
something else that I feel like just
came up in conversation or something
that is too heavy for me the pursuit of
happiness with Will Smith is genuinely
too heavy I saw it once when I was like
when around when it came out it
destroyed me no that's scene where like
his boss asks him for five dollars to
pay for the cab and it's like all he has
in his wallet like I I like I was not
okay like certain like like certain
things like I don't have the inner piece
to watch like yeah that's one of them of
course like all the Holocaust movies I
can't you've just seen them once and
then ever again yeah never again
remember never never again
are you ready for our next story
I actually just saw the funniest bit on
stand up stand up on Tick Tock hmm
actually I hate like reciting stand up
it's just move on it's like never as
funny as you think it's gonna be you
know
I'll send you the link I'll send a link
send me the link our next story Nikita
dragon has been arrested and charged
with felony battery on a police officer
I heard about this Nikita Dragon was
arrested on Monday night after she was
caught walking around a luxury Miami
Hotel pool naked TMZ reported that the
YouTuber had allegedly been walking
around the pool area in her bathing suit
and being disorderly for hours Hotel
staff claim that when they were asked
when they asked her to put her clothes
back on she intentionally threw water on
them which is when the cops were called
however by the time the police got there
the 26 year old had retreated to her
hotel room and was blasting loud music
in an attempt to get her under control
police officers and hotel security
knocked on her door several times before
she finally greeted them but when they
told her she needed to abide by the
hotel rules she allegedly slammed the
door then she allegedly opened the door
and told officers do you want more
before throwing a water bottle at them
she was arrested on the spot following
the incident the influencer was booked
for felony battery on a police officer
misdemeanor disorderly conduct and
misdemeanor her battery she was booked
at Miami-Dade County's Turner Guilford
Knight Correctional Center it's unclear
if she's been released
so this is a crazy story but I also saw
you know what's so weird about like Zoom
court is that like people can like join
so somebody joined like her arraignment
and she did ask when she would be
transferred out of the men's unit they
put her in the men's unit which is
really sad
and like really unsafe
why I don't know
it was really sad like I saw it on tick
tock oh I know
um so she was probably like drunk or
something right like I don't think
anybody like acts like that normally
yeah I'm sure she was like drunk and
maybe Thanksgiving it's giving Luann de
lesseps in Jupiter yeah maybe some drugs
party drugs who knows yeah no honestly
like not I follow her on Instagram
actually unfollowed her today just
because like I realized like
it's not like my favorite content but I
was watching her Miami content like this
weekend and I was like it looked so wild
I remember like remarking being like
damn she looks like she's having a good
time like she never really posted like
that before so maybe she was on like a
bender or something we've all been yeah
I don't know it's just not not good
behavior like you don't have a good MGP
you can party hard without assaulting a
police officer I think and the hotel
staff like come on right right like come
on
go out like go to a party go to the
clubs like it's Miami there's a million
places where they welcome Behavior like
that yeah you don't but I'm sure she was
staying at like a really Swanky Hotel
yeah
can't act like that no you can't
are you ready for our next story if it's
the next story that's sponsored by
betterhelp oh it is and it's actually a
really great compliment to the next
story
well thank you better help for
sponsoring today's episode life doesn't
come with a user manual so when it's not
working for you it's normal to feel
stuck navigating any of life's
challenges can make you feel unsure
whether it's a career change a new
relationship or becoming a parent
therapists are trained to help you
figure out the cause of challenging
emotions and learn productive coping
skills which makes therapy the closest
thing to a guided tour of the complex
engine called you so betterhelp is the
world's largest therapy service they
have matched three million people with
professionally licensed embedded
therapists that are available 100 online
Plus what's so great about betterhelp is
that it's affordable you just fill out a
brief questionnaire and match with a
therapist if things aren't clicking you
can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime it couldn't be simpler there's
no waiting rooms no traffic and there's
no endless searching for the right
therapist learn more and save 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com toast
what's so great about betterhelp is the
way that you can switch therapists
almost immediately
um because anyone will tell you like in
order to find the right therapist like
you have to shop around a little bit and
and like going and finding new ones
waiting in the office it can be like a
really laborious process that I think
sometimes discourages people from the
idea of therapy in general but doing it
all online you can video chat you can
text you can call it just makes it way
more accessible and way less of a big
deal to switch up your therapists so
again you can learn more and save 10 at
betterhelp help.com toast betterhelp.com
toast
great thank you so much and uh you're
welcome
related similar yet different scientists
are saying that grabbing a shovel and
digging a hole might help you if you're
stressed out there's a tick tock Trend
going around of people digging holes
because science
studies are showing that it can help
relieve stress a student in Scotland
isn't that just like exercise in general
yeah but there's something about hole
digging in particular and for me like my
mind just went to the movie Holes like
all these times
thought that they were just like abusing
these kids but maybe it was stress
relief maybe it was a de-stressing
method a very unorthodox you know kind
of Eastern medicine type of distress
right that also you know they're looking
for the treasure that was buried it's
it's a twofer two birds one stone I
haven't seen holes in a minute is that
why Sigourney Weaver was making all the
kids dig holes yes because there was the
legend that there was a treasure buried
and in the end Shia found the treasure
right shy
[Music]
is like a legend and and what did
Stanley get sent to holes camp for like
what do you get in trouble for it was
like food that's a military school the
first five minutes of the movie that you
know people always miss yeah totally
well you're like making the snacks but
like some delinquent Behavior right but
was he sent there like by this the
government or like his parents I think
by the state okay like it's like
Juvenile Detention and instead of like a
juvenile prison like it's kind of like
dark for a Disney Channel original movie
you know yeah but I mean the end was so
wonderful beautiful
explosion
I need to see this movie it's like again
I haven't seen it in years yeah me
neither I don't know why I remember it
like word for word like for me like a
core memory yeah you literally know
everything about it you're like a whole
historian for me like the iconic scene
is when they eat those radishes like for
some reason that's like seared in my
brain oh that's so funny not for me but
now I I'm or is it an onion like what I
think it's onion
big pull it out of the ground yeah
iconic I can't I was like anyway I like
wanted an onion when I was a kid you
know research is showing that digging
holes can be very therapeutic so people
on Tick Tock are now digging holes just
um
park rangers are saying please fill them
in back in when you're done
don't just leave all these Park Rangers
the park ranger so people are digging
holes on the beach which is so nice and
honestly that seems like a great form of
like mental and physical exercise just
fill them in when you're done
I love that there's a trend on Tick Tock
that's encouraging people to get get
outside and get outside
de-stress I feel like a lot of you know
stress and fatigue actually comes from
Tick Tock so I think this is great I
love that the kids are you know working
on themselves working on themselves and
this is a trend I can get behind The
Tick Tock Trend because most of the tick
tock trends like require you to use your
phone more like to learn the dances all
of these things to watch these videos to
literally memorize these scripts so you
can like film yourself saying something
for what
for like what for likes exactly so this
is real stuff and you know what it goes
back thousands and thousands of years
like
um
digging for thousands of years these men
gave their lives to the Night's Watch
for thousands of years humans have been
digging holes
so true are you gonna go out into your
yard and take a hole later then to
de-stress like once Harry goes down for
a nap no
not gonna break up my yard no I don't
know
I never thought of that at me doing it
you'd have to do it at the beach yeah
but I don't know the shovel's like heavy
I don't think I'm built for hole digging
I definitely agree you're no Stanley
illness no are you gonna go dig some
holes
where in the concrete
in Central Park imagine I show up to
Central Park with a shovel and I start
digging a hole I would get arrested
there's definitely something illegal
about that yeah for sure because it's
like um it's destruction of property
like yeah
and they take Central Park seriously
they do you could probably go to one of
the other parks and do it yeah like one
of the ones that nobody cares about yeah
that they've just let go 100
are you ready for our fifth and final
story final story yeah because we gotta
get into Deer toasters which I'm excited
about we do students in El Paso are very
upset after their SAT exams flew out of
a UPS truck
do you see this
El Paso high school students SAT exams
were lost after test papers flew out of
a UPS truck the school district official
said they're working closely with the
College Board to determine a remedy for
the 55 students whose answer documents
were lost the incident affects students
who took the exam on October 27th and
since then they have decided that the
kids need to retake the SATs because
they wound up in the middle of the road
that ain't [ __ ] right [ __ ] yeah I
wonder though if it's the exact same
test
and now they know the question no
probably not oh my God this the kids who
took the acts are probably like so
[ __ ] happy well it's not everyone
whose tests were lost just the ones who
flew off the you like some of them
stayed on the UPS track oh some of them
flew honestly I feel like this is one of
those like rare situations where the
kids should get like you know a perfect
score like just you know
I no but but to make them retake it like
those tests are like are so difficult
and they they really stress out the kids
like I don't know I think it's this is a
terrible story actually yeah and some of
them are now going to take the acts
instead with no extra because like the
deadline for that is November 4th or
December 10th so they could I mean now
they know what they're gonna write their
essays about the trials and tribulations
of the UPS truck and then maybe they
could write their essay about you know
this dystopian Universe where like if
the test had made it onto the truck like
they would have gone to this college and
lived like that Lily Reinhardt movie and
the Gwyneth Paltrow one sliding doors
yeah but that would be a really good
essay topic but now that they have to
take the SAT again maybe it's a better
score or Worse score and how that
changes their life because this UPS
driver didn't follow protocol
I never really thought about like how
the tests get to like the College Board
whatever it's called yeah like the
standards they just like go through the
mail with everything else no like I
would have assumed it's like a Brink
truck you know like lock and key yeah
that's how seriously like they take
themselves over at the standardized
testing committee right but you couldn't
have that for every school in every
state
no I guess not I really never thought
about it like I just handed in the blue
book and bounced said a prayer
and just wish for the best mm-hmm that
sucks thinking of those campers oh
there's so much that sucks about being a
kid these days honestly yeah between
like missing out on like so many iconic
moments like because of covid and then
like being you know everyone's like
constantly in a state of like depression
and anxiety because of like social media
I'm really glad I grew up like at the
tail end of the digital age
no not the tail end the beginning of the
digital age
you love the digital age I'm a digital
girl you know yeah influencer Mogul
media Empire s Empress your eye clarity
totally I Claudia
um okay should we dive your toasters or
by segment every Wednesday where we try
and help our listeners out to you know
get out of the pickles they found
themselves in yes please so dear
toasters if you ever want to submit it's
deer toasters gmail.com we'll always
keep your [ __ ] Anonymous and you can
write in about anything just try and
keep it brief the need to know
information you know basics
ready
Jackson Claude how are you Dern long
time listener since the early days of
the breath first time writer and I will
keep it brief my precious gem of a man
fiance and I have been together since
high school and we're getting married in
a couple of months he's the best very
loyal funny Charming driven Etc the one
thing is and tell me if I'm overthinking
this is that him and his mom have a kind
of weird relationship they always have
he's the epitome of a mama's boy but
maybe to a fault they are legitimately
always texting I mean 24 7 and he even
sends her good morning beautiful texts
he calls her view sorry he calls her boo
calls her beauty he sends Hearts all the
time back and forth with her I have a
great relationship with his mom so it's
not like she's weird with me or anything
like that but am I right to be a bit
weirded out with the flirtatiousness of
his own mother
sincerely a slightly clamped toaster no
I'm sorry good morning beautiful like
that is reserved for your partner like
that's [ __ ] weird it's weird sure but
now being a boy mom like the thought of
Harry growing up like being engaged to a
wonderful girl but like still
remembering to call his mother beautiful
and like to check in on me just like
show me how much he loves me like Mom
goals mom goals no I'm sorry like there
is a line
and I believe like this crosses the line
it's [ __ ] weird
I also think it's important to know like
what um
like what religion or ethnicity your
husband is because like this is a very
like Jewish voice and their moms are
like very very tight I could see them
like being Jewish not that it matters
but like it is a cultural thing too just
to give more context but I still find it
[ __ ] weird like Ben is extremely
close with his mom like talks to her
multiple times a day on the phone and I
don't think he would ever send a good
morning beautiful text like that's weird
yeah I I don't think there's anything
you really do about it without like
looking jealous of his mom and then you
just like look crazy especially because
like they're not flirting I think that
if you guys stay together and get
married and have kids like this will
work itself out because he won't have
the time to be constantly checking like
sending texts like when there's a baby
crying you know so right if you love him
and everything else is good just
it
you know ignore it and I think this is
the biggest problem in your relationship
then you have a very strong relationship
like if something bothers you it bothers
you and like it is weird yeah and I
think there's a way obviously to tell
your mom like I'm now I'm thinking like
Ben tells his mom that she looks
beautiful like when we go out to dinner
like he's always like Mommy you look so
beautiful
um
so he doesn't say mommy he says mommy
looks so beautiful
um but I do think like the nature of
like the good morning beautiful like I'm
stuck on the good morning beautiful
because that's like what you say to like
a guy you're talking to like you know
when you're in the talking stage or like
you're just starting to date like you'll
get like a good morning beautiful text
like it's weird
as a boy mom now I think it's nice if
you asked me a year ago I'd be totally
with Claudia but like
I'm so happy for this Mom that she is
such a great son who loves her so much
and he's engaged in doing you know in a
proper well-adjusted relationship I
think that as his plate gets Fuller you
know priorities change so just ride it
out would be my advice not you being
like a blindly loyal mom Defender oh
yeah that's your like new energy you're
bringing plot twist yeah I see it from a
different point of view I'm not sure I'm
not just the fiance anymore like I'm the
mom right oh my God that's crazy you're
the mom
all right next up
dear Jax cloud and the stress Bros we
are writing in as a group and we love
you but let's cut to the chase we have a
problem with a friend who is a phone
Snoop for the sake of this story her
name is Rachel she's a part of our
friend group from high school and we've
all been close for over 10 years we've
always noticed that Rachel can be a
little nosy when it comes to our phones
she will peek over shoulders to see who
we're texting even open and read our
text messages if she has our phone while
we're driving
more recently though it's gotten extreme
we found out through one of our close
guy friends that Rachel had taken one of
our phones without our permission and
read a whole group Chatsworth of
conversation that was pertaining to her
the conversation shined a light on a
time when Rachel was in the wrong we use
this group chat to vent and complain
about Rachel Rachel expressed to our guy
friend that she was upset after reading
the messages but she has never brought
it up because she's extremely
non-confrontational should we tell
Rachel that we know she has read those
messages and if so how do we approach
the fact that she continuously invades
our privacy EXO from three toasters in
need of some beautiful stunning and
smart advice oh that's tough call it out
like first you could say hi she [ __ ]
around and found out so you can't even
feel bad about her reading those
messages why is she engaging in this
like emotional self-harm if she wants to
read all these like unkind things about
herself and then not even want to
confront you about it so it's just like
bottling up inside her honestly you need
to do her a favor and bring it up
because she's gonna explode and I would
say one like I know you've read the
group chat about you
um do you want to know where we're
coming from or you just want to read it
be shady and then what's stew behind her
yeah and be like I'm sorry that you had
to like read that but you also crossed a
major line yeah no and I would say once
you figure like explain to her and have
it out over over that group chat
situation you should say like and also
you need to stop reading everyone's
phones you need to stop snooping you
need to stop if I hand you my phone for
something like I I'm not date friends
with a private investigator and like if
you want to be my friend like I'm
allowed a modicum of privacy and I this
[ __ ] needs to stop right like you have
to respect boundaries like they're not
even that crazy
I would like if I felt like a friend who
I love and wanted to stay friends with
was doing something like this I would
just be like the [ __ ] are you doing like
stop yeah well the thing is this isn't
my jam and it's weird Behavior this
isn't my plate mm-hmm
I am sometimes a proponent of snooping
never when it comes to friends like that
snooping not because she like wants to
find out one specific thing like she's
addicted to like just knowing things
about people like it's not like she's
looking yeah he's going in people's
phone and like searching her own name
which would be another self another form
of like yeah emotions who would ever do
that oh my God don't ever I did that
once with a friend who like I have like
a very
um they don't even know like we should
have like a very tumultuous relationship
like we have like time periods where we
don't talk it's not like a peaceful
friendship like my friends from high
school like we've never gotten fights
like that's if I search my name in their
phone I wouldn't find anything like but
this is like a was like a tumultuous and
I found such crazy [ __ ]
um and I'll never do it again it was
like a lesson you have to learn the hard
way because like I'm a curious person
you know yeah and what people say about
you or think about you like is really
not your business like how they treat
you is so and people are really entitled
to like you know have their thoughts
about you like whether you like them or
not yeah so and not everyone like 100 of
the time thinks only positive thoughts
about you even if they're your friend
like you could have done something that
have said them they talked about it with
someone else so I would just say like I
don't want a friendship like this you're
not like
my boss you don't get to like know
however so either change your ways or
that's that on that yeah no and I feel
like she's going to come at the
conversation from like a victim
mentality like I can't believe you guys
said this about me and it's like I feel
like you really need to drill in the
fact that like what she did how she
found out this information
it's like in court when you it's
inadmissible it's inadmissible when you
like illegally get evidence it's
inadmissible like the way she found this
out is illegal so honestly her feelings
on the on the matter don't matter to me
yeah we had this group chat about you
because we wouldn't include you because
we're not Psychopaths and we want to
spare your feelings if you want to know
everything everyone thinks and says
about you like We'll add you next time
and we'll say the same yeah would that
be better yeah and then is [ __ ] better
and then you can spiral into the
conversation about like her General lack
of awareness when it comes to like
boundaries and reading through people's
phones yeah I don't have time for this
like no that's like a psychotic thing to
do people need to act right
people need to act right well our third
and final one which I think we're gonna
have a a difficult time helping because
I really don't know the right answer is
brought to you by neutralfall 30 million
women are impacted by weakened or
thinning hair if you're among them no
you're not alone and that there's a
solution you can trust to deliver
results neutrophil is the number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement it's clinically shown to
improve your hair growth the thickness
of your hair and visible scalp coverage
neutral fall supports help healthy hair
growth from within by targeting five
root causes of thinning stress hormones
the environment nutrition and metabolism
and they're supporting that through
whole body Health they have three unique
formulas to support women throughout all
stages of life including postpartum and
menopause each formula is physician
formulated using natural drug-free
medical grade ingredients and it is
consistently effective dosages so you
can get the most reliable results I know
you experience like a thinning of your
hair postpartum you had like great Thick
Growth during hair during pregnancy and
then after it was kind of sparse is that
right yeah thanks for shouting that out
um no I lost so much hair around month
four postpartum and I had to go through
that and really like there's no way to
thwart it in in a real way to experience
it but then once it's over like and
you're in a phase of regrowth like there
are so many great supplements like
neutrophil that you can take and I'm
actually in my regrowth season which I
never want to complain about because I'm
just so happy that it's here and it's
back and that everything that I'm doing
is working but it's like very annoying
and I need a serious Pomade
um so that it's not always poking out
from my head but I'm not good in a
clinical study 86 of women reported
improved hair growth after six months
you can grow thicker healthier hair and
support the toast by going to
nutrifold.com enter the promo code toast
and save 15 off your first month
subscription it's their best to offer
anywhere and it is only available to the
US customers for a limited time plus you
get free shipping on every order you can
also get the 15 off neutral full and
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com and the code is
toast all right our third and final dear
toasters again thank you to everyone who
wrote in hello Jackson Claude let me cut
to the chase let me cut to the chase
with this one my 16 year old cousin
messaged me last night a photo of a
positive pregnancy test and she asked
for help
she's extremely immature and sheltered
and she's been going through a lot
mentally this year I know her family
doesn't know what to make of the
depression and anxiety that she has her
family is very conservative and I know
this won't go over well with them
obviously because she's 16. she came to
me because I know she trusts me I'm her
28 year old fun cousin but I don't know
if I should tell her mom or what I
should do I don't want her to lose my
trust and she doesn't have a lot of
people to rely on what do I do
thanks
that's tough I mean you want to be like
fun cool cousin but like this is like
such a big deal and potentially like a
medical
thing that like you have to tell her
parents like the worst thing you could
do to a 16 year old she'll she'll hate
you I know I would first approach it
like I would go to her and be like we
need to tell your mom like yeah because
what you need right now is support like
to go through something like this alone
and even though you have your 28 year
old cousin like it's not enough like you
need your family you need your parents
and you need your mom so I would try and
convince her like we'll go tell your mom
together yeah that's gonna be okay like
I'll be here the whole time like in case
you need you know someone to have your
back or anything if she was completely
against it like refuses I would go ahead
and tell her mom because of course she's
going to be so upset but one day she
will know why you did what you did and
what she needs is support resources
knowledge family people who let her know
that they'll be there for her and that
like you know hopefully whatever
decision that she would want to make
like that she is supported and that she
would have what she needs to make that
decision so this is not something a 16
year old can go through on her own with
their 28 year old cousin you I try and
convince her to do it with you but if if
she wouldn't I would go to her mom
yourself yeah yeah no that's a really
good call hopefully like the the first
way she is down to do
um and I think you also just have to be
prepared for the fact that she probably
won't be ready and you'll probably have
to tell her parents behind her back and
like you just have to be prepared for
her like hating you for a couple years
yeah but she's not gonna hate you for
her whole life and no you will have done
what's best for her because
she shouldn't have to go through that
alone and if she has people around her
then they should
she should use them and and they should
be able to help her whatever it is
um
yeah I think that's the right the right
call and it's like fun to be like the
cool cousin cool aunt but like this is
like I think like a little too serious
of a situation because I do think that
there are people in your life like if
Harry you know has a problem and he
wants to tell me like and it's not that
serious like I'm not gonna tell you like
I am going to be like the cool ant yes
but sometimes like there are situations
that go beyond that and this is
obviously one of them right and I don't
know what she's like told you and if she
knows what she wants to do but if she's
um
if she doesn't know like what she's
doing like she
She's So Young she needs more support
more help and like people who and people
who she loves and respects and like
their opinion I think I think all of
that matters yeah no she's just far too
young to even attempt to do this alone
and honestly you're only 28 like I'm 28
what the [ __ ] do we know you know right
right like 28 is like not an adult
yeah so if you're me
I think that assuming like that her
parents are loving and care about her
more than anything which I would hope
that they do
um you should tell them yeah I think so
too hopefully together
thank you to everyone who wrote in
hopefully we were as helpful as possible
again if you ever want to write in or if
your submission hasn't been read yet
feel free to resend it maybe we didn't
read it because it was like a little too
long
um dear toasters gmail.com is the email
account we will always stay Anonymous of
course that is our show that is also our
final um episode for the week we are
back in studio on Tuesday after my tour
I can't wait to see everyone in Durham
in Charlotte and in Birmingham this
weekend checks I hope you enjoy your
time off spend some time with world dini
give him big slobbery wet kisses from
his auntie I will also the crown drops
tomorrow so yeah every time I read an
article about like the crown like the
date of when it drops is changing
because I think it changes and it drops
in different countries at different
times anyways it drops around this
weekend so hopefully by Tuesday we'll
have a recap for you guys oh my God yeah
well I'm traveling a lot so I should
have a lot of time wait that's so
exciting yeah
and there's tons of good [ __ ] on the
patreon if you're missing us tomorrow or
Friday or Monday
um this is the last big leg of the tour
the uh last shows are Delaware and my uh
special taping in New York so the tour
was really supposed to be over this
weekend so there won't be like a bunch
of missed travel dates for some time so
I appreciate everyone's patience with me
thus far on the tour missing episodes
Jackie of course for always holding down
the fort I appreciate you and I can't
wait to rock it out at these last couple
of shows I'm getting emo it's the end of
n log it's end log
end log
thank you so much
hummus or two thank you so much for
listening to the toast the Millennium
Morning Show where we deliver the past
five stories you need to know everybody
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube please don't
forget to subscribe and give this video
a thumbs up we're also available podcast
anywhere podcast gonna be found at
Spotify
and that's the toaster leave a five-star
review about our beautiful standing and
smart we are oh no about how wickedly
talented we are hope you guys have an
amazing day happy hump day and we'll see
you back here on Tuesday love you dearly
bye love you bye